[Música]
son las 8:29 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima nosotros continuamos en directo a
América edición nocturna seguimos
comentandoles los principales hechos del
día Les agradecemos su sintonía y vamos
con los titulares de esta jornada
se cumplieron los primeros cien días en
El poder del presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el mandatario
cargó contra el legado de su antecesor
Yahir bolsonario y reiteró su compromiso
de favorecer a los más necesitados
también resaltó que la transición
energética está en marcha tenemos
análisis
el un nuevo tiroteo en la ciudad
estadounidense de Louisville en Kentucky
dejó cuatro muertos y nueve heridos los
hechos ocurrieron en un banco y el
tirador que trabajaba en el lugar
realizó el ataque con un rifle según la
ong violence en lo que va de 2023 se han
registrado 146 tiroteos masivos
miles de colonos judíos marcharon hacia
cisjordania para exigir al Primer
Ministro Benjamín de tanyahu Que cumpla
su promesa de ampliar los asentamientos
por su parte palestinos de la localidad
de Monte savig reaccionaron
enfrentándose con las autoridades
israelíes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Brasil porque se
cumplieron los primeros 100 días en El
poder del presidente Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva y en su discurso televisado el
mandatario condenó el legado de su
predecesor Yahir bolsonaro a quien acusó
de perpetuar El fascismo a su vez se
declaró optimista sobre el futuro
económico del país y reiteró su
compromiso de trabajar en favor de los
necesitados afirmó que el gobierno
ampliará las acciones en contra de la
violencia machista y racista y aseguró
que el medio ambiente es un compromiso a
largo plazo
armonía
Brasil volvió a cultivar la armonía y la
convivencia republicana entre los tres
poderes de los cuales el mayor ejemplo
fue la rápida reacción al intento de
golpe de estado del 8 de enero al día
siguiente la barbarie los tres poderes
marcharon juntos del Palacio de Gobierno
del plan alto del tribunal supremo
pasando por el Congreso Nacional para
decir alto y claro no al fascismo Sí a
la democracia
Y sí a demografía
para el análisis de esta información nos
acompaña Oscar vilena él es profesor de
derecho constitucional doctor en
ciencias políticas por la universidad de
Sao Paulo en Brasil Bienvenido a France
24 a 100 días de llegar al palacio de
plan alto el mandatario ha hecho de su
bandera recuperar los programas de ayuda
sociales sin embargo su aprobación ronda
apenas el 40 por ciento A qué se debe
este fenómeno
en primer lugar porque fue una elección
muy muy apretada de Luis Ignacio tiene
apenas dos por ciento de
su competidor Entonces es natural país
dividido hay un grupo muy grande de
lectores de derecho
y que rechacen la administración
para después que los programas lo han
tomado los programas sociales se deban
tener un efecto a más a medio plazo
entonces pensó que ese es dos razones
luego a que lo apoyo al presidente a
este momento no esté encima de los 40
por ciento Bueno usted lo estaba
mencionando y veíamos en el discurso del
presidente Lula que arremetió contra
Yahir bolsonaro en medio de un ambiente
tan polarizado y con el antecedente del
Ataque a los poderes del 6 de enero Cómo
analiza usted este mensaje del
mandatario
por favor se puede repetir la pregunta
porque no no puede eludir le pregunto
que en medio de la polarización que vive
Brasil este en este mensaje en este
discurso Lula cargó contra bolsonaro y
pues vemos esto con el antecedente del
ataque del 6 de enero Cómo analiza usted
este discurso del mandatario
está teniendo una dificultad de hacer un
gobierno más amplio internos de agrupar
Alianza
entonces este discurso sí refuerza a
aquellos que son de la izquierda y más
los grupos identitarios con cual Luna
tiene mucha facilidad de hablar pero no
amplía para los grupos de Centro que
muchos de él hubieron votado para para
la primera elección y después cambiaron
para Lula Entonces pienso que sí lo el
presidente hay que hacer un esfuerzo más
grande para incorporar a los los
seguimientos de centro a su plataforma
de gobierno Bueno y con el actual
panorama que tiene Brasil Cuáles se
pueden considerar los principales retos
que tiene el mandatario para el resto de
su administración
pero pienso que hay dos objetivos más
claros Primero este
envolver a la economía brasileña en un
ciclo virtuoso que poesa dar cuenta
social entonces la economía es sin duda
de ñuma lo
los desafío más importante de este
momento hay también que hacerse un
proceso de
desmocionalización
de las áreas de seguridad pública que
quedaron muy capturadas por los
gobiernos de extrema derecha Entonces
pienso que hay un programa económico por
en Plaza con las repercusiones sociales
de esto que también un programa de
defensa del Estado de derecho de la
Democracia Señor bilenno usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Gracias en Estados Unidos este lunes se
registró un nuevo tiroteo en el estado
de Kentucky que dejó cinco muertos
incluido el tirador y nueve heridos los
hechos se produjeron una entidad
bancaria donde trabajaban todas las
víctimas y el presunto responsable el
presidente Joe biden condenó el hecho y
criticó al partido republicano por no
lograr un consenso acerca de La
regulación de armas en el país
un nuevo tiroteo en luta a Estados
Unidos luego de que un joven armado de
23 años irrumpiera en un banco de la
ciudad de luibil en el estado de
Kentucky las autoridades investigan las
razones que habrían llevado al tirador a
cometer el delito pero confirmaron que
se trata de un antiguo trabajador de la
entidad bancaria que además estaba
transmitiendo en vivo
escuché un clic del rifle y la señora de
mi lado dijo qué diablos y luego
empezaron los disparos no pude verle la
cara pero era un rifle largo
estaba entrando al trabajo y escuché lo
que parecían disparos luego había dos
oficiales de policía y me dijeron que
corriera Así que salí corriendo la
policía local informó que el agresor
murió dentro del banco en medio de un
intercambio de disparos también
agregaron que respondieron a la
emergencia en tan solo tres minutos vía
Twitter el presidente Joe biden condenó
el tiroteo masivo y criticó a los
republicanos por no lograr consensos
para regular las leyes de armas en el
país por su parte el gobernador del
estado realizó una rueda de prensa
visiblemente afectado luego de contar
que algunas de las víctimas eran
cercanas a él
esto es horrible
tengo un amigo muy cercano que no
sobrevivió hoy tengo otro que tampoco lo
logró y uno que está en el hospital
Espero que se salve entonces pido sus
oraciones para que lo logre según la
organización
la cual sigue la violencia Armada en
Estados Unidos en lo que va de 2023 se
han registrado más de 10.500 incidentes
con armas de fuego incluyendo tiroteos
masivos y suicidios
continuamos en Estados Unidos Porque el
portavoz de seguridad Nacional de la
Casa Blanca John Kirby aseguró de este
lunes que Washington ha tratado de
tranquilizar a sus aliados tras la
filtración de documentos secretos del
pentágono que sugieren que el gobierno
pudo estadounidense pudo haber espiado
algunos de sus socios como Corea del Sur
Ucrania e Israel el funcionario destacó
que está haciendo todo lo posible para
identificar la fuente de la filtración
Pero todavía no se ha logrado el
departamento de Justicia ya lleva a cabo
una investigación criminal para
determinar lo ocurrido
vamos a la ciudad francesa de Marsella
donde las autoridades informaron que
aumentó a seis el número de víctimas
atrás el desplome de un edificio este
domingo que fue causado por una
explosión dos personas permanecen
desaparecidas por lo que continúan las
tareas de rescate el alcalde de Marsella
anunció esta tarde que las banderas del
ayuntamiento ondearán a media hasta en
señal de duelo la principal hipótesis es
que el desplome fue ocasionado por la
explosión posiblemente provocada por una
fuga de gas
y vamos a Israel donde miles de colonos
judíos marcharon hacia sis Jordania para
exigirle al Primer Ministro Benjamín de
tanyahu Que cumpla su promesa de ampliar
los asentamientos figuras reconocidas
del gobierno de extrema derecha
estuvieron en la movilización por su
parte palestinos de la localidad de
Monte savi reaccionaron a esta
movilización
enfrentándose con las autoridades
israelíes Samuel Salgado tiene los
detalles
una nueva escena de violencia en las
disjordania ocupada miles de colonos
marcharon hacia el asentamiento de
eviatar con el fin de presionar el
Primer Ministro israelí Benjamín a que
autorice su repoblación tras ordenar su
evacuación en 2021 el ministro de
seguridad y tamar bengavir conocido por
sus posturas radicales participó de la
marcha junto a él ministros y activistas
que buscan más asentamientos judíos
lo llamamos la gran marcha de Qatar para
presionar al gobierno para que cumpla
con su obligación de construir este
asentamiento
se ha convertido en un símbolo para que
lo sigan muchos más
la movilización de colonos despertó la
ira de los palestinos en el monte
los colonos israelíes piensan que
regresarán al monte pero los habitantes
de beita nunca los dejaremos regresar a
esta montaña donde cayeron doce Mártires
y resultaron heridos cinco mil hermanos
la ONU es Clara en condenar la
ampliación de los asentamientos judíos a
los que considera ilegales cerca de
500.000 israelíes han ocupado sus
Jordania contra una población de 3
millones de palestinos cuyas familias
han habitado estas tierras desde antes
de la creación del Estado Israel en 1948
la escalada de las tensiones ocurre tras
una semana violenta con dos ataques uno
en sys Jordania y otro en tel aviv en
los que murieron al menos cuatro
personas y por la muerte de hoy de un
palestino de 15 años en una redada
militar en un campo de refugiados en
cisjordania y en medio de una
inestabilidad política en Israel debido
a la polémica reforma de justicia de
netanyahu la violencia en 2023 ha dejado
más de 90 palestinos muertos y al menos
19 israelíes
[Música]
cambiamos de tema porque china llevó a
cabo el tercer y último día de
ejercicios militares en el estrecho de
formosa que separa el país de Taiwán los
ejercicios de este lunes se enfocaron en
simular un cerco marítimo a la isla y
siguen ataques simulados decenas de
barcos y alrededor de 100 aviones
participaron en las maniobras que se
produjeron en respuesta a la reunión de
la presidenta de Taiwán y el presidente
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos Kevin mccarthy
91 aeronaves y 12 buques navales fueron
los activos militares que utilizó el
ejército Popular de liberación chino en
el último día de sus ejercicios
militares en el estrecho de Taiwán en el
tercer día de las maniobras las fuerzas
armadas chinas llevaron a cabo
simulaciones militares tanto de un
bloqueo a la isla como de ataques aéreos
a posiciones estratégicas dentro de
territorio taiwanés hoy utilizaron el
portaaviones como insignia de su flota
naval está armado con lanzamisiles de
corto alcance y es la primera vez que se
utilizan ejercicios militares el
portavoz del Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores expresó que la independencia
de Taiwán y la paz en el estrecho que
separa ambos territorios es una
combinación imposible
Esperamos que en la comunidad
internacional reconozca la verdad en la
cuestión de Taiwán que se atienen
incondicionalmente al principio una sola
China la independencia de Taiwán y la
estabilidad en el estrecho son
mutuamente exclusivas
desde Taiwán la preocupación por un
ataque a la isla es real
si se desencadenaron conflicto militar
con las armas que tiene China que son
muy potentes y avanzadas no podríamos
defendernos
el gobierno de Taiwán condenó las
maniobras militares de China diciendo
que socavan la paz y la estabilidad por
su parte Estados Unidos El Aliado más
importante de Taiwán mandó un destructor
en la zona Estados Unidos aseguró que
Francia es uno de sus principales
aliados para hacer frente a China esto
pese a los comentarios del presidente
francés Emanuel que marcó de distancia
ante las políticas estadounidenses hacia
Taiwán vedan patela portavoz del
departamento de estado aseguró que
Francia es el Aliado más antiguo de
Estados Unidos previamente en una
entrevista con el diario le secón abogó
por construir una autonomía europea
respecto a la política exterior de
Washington y de Beijing en temas como
Taiwán el partido republicano calificó
como una traición la declaración del
francés mientras que desde Beijing
aseguraron que las palabras de macom
muestran el fin de la estrategia
estadounidense de obligar a Europa a
hacer algo contra china
Así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ella llega mal venotman con toda la
actualidad del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]